hello oppressors
and oppressed alike it is march
9th 2021 i'm dave rubin this is the
reuben report
direct message and before you do
anything else i want you to click that
subscribe button
click that notification bell and see
what happens
all right we got a big show for you
today we're doing four stories
one involving joe biden the man has
problems
uh the second one involving don lemon
the man has problems
uh the third one involving the new york
times the paper has problems
and the fourth involving san francisco a
city with problems
before we get to any of that though guys
i want to talk to you
about ancestry.com you know there are
many paths to finding your family story
whichever way you choose tracing your
family generations back with a family
tree
or uncovering your ethnicity with
ancestry dna
it's easy to get started with ancestry
you could find a famous relative or
perhaps a photo of your great grandma as
a little girl
whatever you find it's sure to change
the whole way you look at your family
history
and yourself after all the story of your
family is the story of you
with the ongoing pandemic it's easy to
feel disconnected from your loved ones
but researching your history is a fun
activity
for the whole family to enjoy and the
stories you learn about your shared past
can bring you closer together for
example
yesterday i found out that i'm part of
the british royal family
just kidding i didn't find that out but
we have traced my family back to like
over 200 years to lithuania ancestry dna
can reveal
ethnic origins and provide historical
details that bring
your unique family stories to life
ancestry dna doesn't just tell you which
countries you're from but can also
pinpoint the specific regions within
them
giving you insightful geographic detail
about your history
trace the paths of your recent ancestors
and learn how and why your family moved
from place to place
around the world no other dna test
delivers such a unique interactive
experience
grab an ancestry dna kit and start a
free trial to amplify your discoveries
with ancestry's billions
of records and now through march 17th
with ancestry.com st patrick's day sale
you can find your family's connections
to ireland start exploring your family
story today
head to my url at ancestry.com reuben to
get your
ancestry dna kit and start your free
trial that's ancestry.com
reuben and now back to me all right guys
so you know we've done a bunch of
stories here probably over the course
of a couple months where joe biden
either doesn't know where he is doesn't
know who he's talking to
forgets what he's talking about etc etc
and i always preface all of these
stories
by saying i'm not mocking those with
dementia
i'm not mocking those with cognitive
problems i've mentioned a few times
that my grandmother had dementia
sort of the beginnings of alzheimer's
and when i was doing stand-up in new
york so i was working mostly at night
i would spend a lot of time with her
during the days and i used to take her
to doctors and geriatric doctors and
talk about the medications and all that
stuff and you know the constant
repetition and forgetting words and
frustration and and all of those weird
things
one of the interesting things that ended
up happening to my grandmother was
she started in her later years to forget
a lot of her problems and then in many
ways in her last
two or three years was the happiest that
i ever remember her to be it was an odd
side effect of
i guess forgetting some of your past
which is sort of depressing at some
level but
but a weird a weird side effect
nonetheless anyway i don't bring up the
joe biden stuff to mock
people with these problems these these
are serious problems alzheimer's is
perhaps the the in some ways the worst
of all
diseases that that you could end up with
right like a horrific
way to die like there there are other i
mean lou gehrig's disease there there's
some others that are
that are pretty horrible but i i don't
bring up the joe biden stuff
to mock any of this um even though it's
very easy to do that but there is a
massive
problem that we have right now and we're
going to show you a clip in just a
second that's going viral right now
but the massive problem is not just
that it is very obvious to anyone that's
paying attention that something is wrong
with joe biden
but it's that we've all known it since
before he was elected
and no one in mainstream media will talk
about it and
you have to remember the machinery that
is around the president of the united
states
do you think that dr joe by jill biden
does not know about joe biden do you
think that barack obama and hillary
clinton and all of the people around all
of this and you don't think kamala
harris is licking her chops
and you don't think it's perhaps a
national security threat that the
president of the united states is having
trouble remembering
basic things and several times saying he
doesn't even know where he is
but you wouldn't know any of this if you
only watch mainstream media why
is it that cnn refuses to cover this why
is it that msnbc
refuses to cover this and then yesterday
when the clip that we're about to show
you
went viral and it went bananas viral on
twitter
what did twitter do well it actually
allowed it to go
viral in the in the section you know
with the section where they show you
what's trending
but they added commentary to point to a
moment
about a year ago when donald trump
accidentally called tim cook of apple
the ceo of apple tim cook
when he actually called him tim apple
instead of tim cook
so they added this editorial thing so
that yeah you'd maybe see the biden clip
that we're going to show you in just a
moment but really what would trigger you
in your brain would be oh but donald
trump
once screwed up somebody's name but
we're well beyond the point of screwing
up someone's name everyone screws up
someone's name every now and again
everyone
you might forget an instance or like
everyone has
some stuff you could be very busy and
not remember exactly what happened what
all of that stuff is there but we we
actually have a massive scandal
unfolding right now
and the bigger scandal is that we're not
even allowed to talk about the scandal
so this is joe biden
yesterday he not only can't remember who
his secretary of defenses
he can't even remember where the
secretary of defense works
you might have heard of the place it
starts with a p let's take a look
just want to thank you both and i want
to thank the
the former general i keep calling him
general my
my the guy who runs that outfit over
there
i want to make sure we thank the
secretary
for all he's done to try to implement
what we just talked about
and for recommending these two women for
promotion
thank you all may god bless you all and
may god protect our troops
okay so joking aside goodness aside
that's just depressing he says the guy
who runs that outfit over there because
not only can't he remember the defense
secretary's name
he can't remember that the defense
secretary works at the pentagon
what's even more bizarre about this is
you know it is very very obvious we all
know this
that joe biden is obviously not just
going up there and speaking off the top
of his head now he has notes right i've
got i've got a couple notes
here when i do this show but he also has
a teleprompter which means he's just
reading all he has to do is read off the
teleprompter i've mentioned this a
couple times before
sometimes i read off a teleprompter like
when i'm doing this show i'm not reading
off a teleprompter right now i'm just
talking directly to you but if i'm
reading a quote
we put it on the teleprompter so i can
look directly at you while i'm
reading the specific quote and by the
way reading off a teleprompter it is a
little bit of a skill
it is not the easiest thing when you see
anyone
even great orators when you see donald
trump speaking and he goes off the cuff
a lot but you know the way that
politicians are able to look over here
and look over here and look straight and
keep on point it's because they're
looking at different teleprompters
often what they have sometimes you can
see them at like the conventions i
have a very vivid memory of watching
barack obama give a speech at the height
of
obama's popularity and you can see they
have like these blank it's
basically like a blank screen so it
looks basically like a piece of glass
and using a reflection usually
they can just read off it so you read
part here then you read part here
you read part here and it looks like
you're paying attention and completely
extemporaneous and the rest of it what's
disturbing about this is
he can't remember not only the defense
secretary's name he can't remember
the pentagon and then he seemingly can't
remember the name of those two women
but he's supposedly reading this all off
a temp uh off a
teleprompter as well so that is
a little disturbing is his ability to
read breaking down is
the teleprompter guy screwing with him
and then at the end the way he kind of
stands there
and it's like he knows something's not
right so anyway i'm not
doing this all as some like partisan you
know the democrats or evil kind of thing
but
the democrats are kind of evil the fact
that the entire machine knows this and
this man is not going to be president
for four years and where is anyone
talking about this
so this is another one of those things
when i talk about how we're in a reality
war
if you have friends that only watch cnn
only watch msnbc only read
the washington post in the new york
times and they don't pay attention to
what's on youtube
and twitter and everything else they
would never know about this so then you
might say to them hey you know
joe biden's been forgetting where he is
and can't remember the name of his
descent defense secretary and the rest
of it
and then they'd go well i don't i i
never heard of any of that well
and it's like well then you kind of live
in two different realities
and the the bigger issue here is that at
some point it's going to get so bad and
their ability to hide him where he
hasn't given an official press
conference yet
we know he didn't do a state of the
union they won't be able to hide him you
know they're going to keep hiding him as
much as possible but at some point
they won't be able to hide him enough or
or there will be just like an accidental
breakdown in full public view like a
full on breakdown
and then what's going to happen and mark
my words we can bookmark this video
all of the people around him are going
to have to turn on each other
they are going to have they're going to
be like rats on a sinking ship
trying to get off that ship but there
ain't going to be nowhere to go because
they they're all in on it together
they're all in on a very evil secret
that the president of the united states
is mentally compromised i mean this is
the guy
with the which with the launch codes for
the nukes and he doesn't have to ask
anybody i'm pretty sure he can just go
launch some nukes you know what one of
the side effects of
dementia is it's it's anger sudden
outbursts
things like that do you think that this
is a problem by the way completely
unrelated they got rid of the two dogs i
guess they had two german shepherds
at the white house two of biden's dogs
and apparently one of them bit somebody
yesterday
so they're sending them back to delaware
and i guess wasn't it a few weeks ago or
right before
he was sworn in he apparently pulled a
dog's tail and that's what caused him to
fall and break his foot i mean
the scriptwriters aren't even that good
with any of this stuff anyway i'm going
to keep showing you this stuff because
it needs to be seen it just needs to be
seen like something ain't right here
and and by the way if you're an enemy of
america don't pay too much attention to
this everything's fine there's nothing
to see here okay
uh all right let's move on to don lemon
of the
news network formerly known as cnn
uh don lemon is an anchor over at cnn we
used to be kind of friendly actually i
had him on the show once a long time ago
but you guys may have seen this harry
prince harry
meghan markle interview with oprah from
a day or two ago i didn't cover it
yesterday because i just don't really
care
about this stuff it's just not something
that i'm that interested in there's a
lot of things
going on in the world i don't really
care about the british monarchy i did
watch
um i did watch the crown i do
like downton abbey not exactly about the
crown but i do like some of that stuff
but like it doesn't seem that relevant
that a bunch of rich people have some
issues and blah blah blah
anyway it was going viral yesterday but
i thought this was interesting
so in the interview they talk about sort
of racism
within the royal family and we don't
even have to get into all the specifics
about that but don lemon was analyzing
it yesterday on cnn and listen to what
he says here
about accusations of racism it's it's
really interesting
brianna also people say well we haven't
heard from the other side what's the
other side going to say
they're going to say of course we're not
racist or whatever but what did they do
think about their actions they they did
not stand up for
their own because their own was married
to a black woman had a black child
they didn't listen to him inside of the
royal family they let him go they let
him leave the country they wouldn't come
to terms with
what they wanted to do so listen we've
only heard from one side but that one
side at this point
rings very true oh right we've only
heard from one
side the side accusing the other side of
being racist but that rings true
so you know we're just gonna run with
that because we're journalists over here
at cnn i mean that that is pure
nonsensical dribble now without getting
into
all the minutia of the whole thing in
essence meghan markle
who married prince harry is claiming
that there was some racism within the
family
because apparently and i swear to you i
don't pay attention to this stuff so i
swear to you until today i did not know
that
i'm being told she's a quarter black i
did not know that
she looks white to me she looks like a
white italian girl that i grew up with
in long island that's what she looks
like to me
i didn't know she was a quarter black i
don't particularly care
that she's a quarter black but she's
saying that there was some racism in the
family around
her quarter blackness now i want to just
read the quote from lemon again we've
got the quote here
what's the other side going to say
they're going to say
of course we're not racist or whatever
we have only heard from one side
but that one side at this point rings
very true you know this accusation of
racism i know you guys know this because
we see this get thrown
this is what the left does with
absolutely everything this is what the
wolksters
do with absolutely everything everyone
who disagrees with them is a racist
and not only are you even if you agree
with them you still might be a racist
because you have to be actively
anti-racist which in most cases actually
means racist because you're constantly
obsessed
with race but this this accusation and
that oh well
what of course they're going to say
they're not racist because that's what a
racist would say
think how deeply dangerous that is think
how reverse of due process that is
or of of any sort of um basic ability to
have a functional society where you can
defend yourself
from an accusation so someone can just
accuse you of something i mean imagine
if someone just accused don lemon of
pedophilia and then it was like well
don you're a pedophile so and then whoa
you denied it well of course that's what
a pedophile would do and and in a weird
way
i was discussing this with greg gutfeld
yesterday just privately so greg shout
out to you because this sort of came
from you first
but what we were talking about basically
was you know if you accuse someone
uh of pedophilia right that's that's
basically like the worst thing you could
be
accused of right let's say you accuse
someone of pedophilia and it's
and it's not true well then i'm pretty
sure at that point that person
could sue you either for a libel or
slander right you'd have a pretty if you
could prove that you weren't a pedophile
although
the burden of proof shouldn't be on you
but in essence you'd be
accusing someone of something that they
are not and then there are legal
ramifications that people have to fight
back against that
how is that very different than
baselessly being accused of being a
racist
right but we let everyone accuse
everyone of being a racist and this is a
very very dangerous thing i want to pull
up one other thing here because i truly
did not know
i did not know i don't care about these
things i don't really care about the
royal family that much
you know we left england because we
weren't thrilled with the royal family
um i like them in sitcoms but like
that's pretty much it for me and i would
loosely quote
lieutenant frank drebin from uh naked
gun and i posted this video yesterday
that for as
silly as the idea of a queen is we must
treat these people with respect okay so
that's my feelings on the whole thing
but i truly did not know that meghan
markle
was a quarter black i suppose
and that means that her baby because
this was all about her baby that they
were saying something about the baby the
baby was too dark or something the
baby's an eighth i guess that means the
baby
if she's a quarter right then that means
the baby's in eighth black so let's put
the picture up
so this is this is her and the baby
that's her and the baby
okay she looks white to me i mean she
looks like
every italian girl that i knew in long
island growing up
okay that's what she looks like to me
and and the baby looks white
but i don't care i want to be very clear
about this i don't care
and i don't think anyone else cares and
i'm gonna go out on a limb
and guess that no one really in the
royal family
cared either that you're telling me
someone in the royal family
saw that baby and thought that that baby
uh was too black and that was going to
create a problem like
this is all this is literally like some
of the most powerful people
in the world being interviewed by a
billionaire
going woe is me and anyway i only bring
this up not even to make it all about
that but this was really more about what
don lemon did there which is just so
dangerous
because any of us could be accused of
anything and then
if their answer is oh but saying you're
not the racist you're not the pedophile
well that proves that you are
well that's a that's a really dangerous
game by the way just in the last few
minutes piers morgan
who is a terrible terrible interviewer
who uh replaced my friend larry king
over at cnn years ago and then in many
ways led to the downfall so much of
what's wrong with cnn the overly
sensational headlines and just the
complete destruction of journalism
had to do with them bringing piers
morgan aboard uh he just quit the uk
morning show good morning britain
after one of his co-hosts i think it was
what the weatherman was
criticizing uh his behavior towards
megan
and uh then piers morgan i just saw this
right before we started he then stormed
off the air so now he's left
the uk morning show however will they
continue we'll find out
but speaking of terrible places of
journalism not journalism uh the new
york
times did a incredible
really i would say a staggeringly
ridiculous hit piece
on missouri senator josh hawley the
other day
the headline is josh hawley is not going
anywhere
how did he get here now okay now first
off
we know that if the new york times is
going to do
a profile on a republican we know what i
mean you already know where this is
going you think you know where this is
going he's kind of some kind of
right-wing maniac
maybe he's a a racist or a homophobe or
a transphobic something like that yeah
you know that
so we know of course if the new york
times is going to you know do a piece on
one of these people of course they're
going to put them in the worst light and
if they're going to
do a piece on a democrat like try to
imagine what a new york piece
a new york times piece on aoc or on
ilhan omar would look like
but the reason i wanted to show you this
one is because it is so staggeringly
ridiculous
that even the embarrassing new york
times should be doubly embarrassed by
how bad
this hit piece is so here's the exact
quote it's just incredible
in recent weeks some of mr holly's old
classmates and teachers
have been aghast at his role in
undermining confidence
in america's elections i've become i've
been very disappointed to see
who he has become said kristin reuter
thompson
a close friend growing up who was once
mr holly's prom date
even his middle school principal barbara
wiebling
has weighed in i'm not surprised he's a
politician and that he's shooting for
the presidency
says mrs wiebling a vocal supporter of
democrats
the only thing is i think he had a
strict
moral upbringing and i was really
disappointed that he would suck the
country into the lies
that trump told about the election i
just think that's wrong
you know what i think is wrong new york
times i think it's you
writing a hit piece on a senator going
to find
people that he was friends with in
middle school the girl he dated
for the prom and talking to some of his
old teachers as if that frames anything
they're telling us that this woman is a
democrat her feelings
are utterly irrelevant and do you think
you're you're not going to believe where
i'm going to go with this one guys
do you think it's possible that that his
feelings
and knowledge about the world might have
changed in the 20-plus years since he's
been out of high school
does any of that seem relevant do you
anyone watching this right now want to
be judged as the person you were
in high school and does it really matter
what your junior high
principal or the gym teacher thought of
your politics and how they've evolved
this is absolute ridiculous but this is
what passes
as journalism at the new york times and
it's
just it's just incredible so i wanted to
give you just a little a little bite of
that because if you have
friends that still still subscribe to
the new york times
you have to sit them down and you have
to sit them down and you have to say
are you okay are you okay we can find
better things to do with this money can
somebody how much is a yearly
subscription to the new york times let's
find out let's find out what it is and
i'll try to come up on the fly
with some things that would be a better
a better use of the money
it's got to be what couple hundred bucks
yearly subscription to the times
we're going to work on that we'll get
back to that all right i'm going to jump
on to the next story we're going to work
on that one
oh it's okay so it looks like it's 17.8
dollars every four weeks for one year
eight dollars every four weeks
for one year give me the math on that
bust out some math for me who's got a
math
you got a you got one of them there are
calculators on that computer
it's eight dollars every four weeks for
one year so multiply that by 52. can you
do that
eight times 52. somebody help me here
we're ballparking it's about 400 bucks
it seems like it's about 400 bucks
work with me yeah about 400 bucks okay
well i've got two math and magicians
over here okay
um the point is for 400 whoever you are
i'm sure you can find better things you
could buy a really
great bottle of like high-end tequila
i've been into tequila lately you guys
know me as a wine guy
but really feeling uh some tequilas
lately you get a great bottle of tequila
and i assure you
after downing an entire bottle of
tequila you will feel better
than reading cover to cover the new york
times
okay we got one more for you so we did a
ridiculous story on joe biden we did a
ridiculous story on don lemon we did a
ridiculous story
on the new york times and now we'll do a
ridiculous story on the san francisco
area because this is this is just
incredible we're going to show you some
videos so
10 bay areas so this is san francisco
area
walgreens and of course you guys all
know walgreens is the
drugstore pharmacy store 10 bay area
walgreens
are closing right now and you might say
well they must be closing because we're
in a pandemic and people aren't going
out as much and they're ordering things
from amazon and it makes
sense that they're closing well actually
that's not why they're closing they're
closing because of the ridiculous
laws or lack thereof that
are being passed in san francisco where
pretty much crime is no longer a crime
here's some video from inside edition
empty shelves at this walgreens drug
store and it's not because of pandemic
related panic shopping
now the store is closing due to what
local reports are calling a spree of
rampant shoplifting and look at this
just
15 minutes after an inside edition crew
showed up at the drugstore
we found this guy jumping over the front
counter
taking an air bed and leaving the store
on his scooter
no questions asked no one's stopping him
there's a lot to talk about there from
that video before we do anything else
the end of the video is just spectacular
so here's a guy he doesn't mind he's
being videotaped apparently by inside
edition
he hops the counter he steals an air
mattress now first off air mattresses i
think we can all agree air mattresses
are just
absolutely terrible anytime anyone in
the history of the world has ever slept
on an air mattress
it slowly deflates overnight it
collapses onto you you end up waking up
in a sweaty
gross covered in rubber and plastic
they're absolutely horrible and
disgusting so this guy will get
what he deserves sure he may not be
going to jail for for stealing the air
mattress but when he wakes up
in in a hot gross stinky
sweat it will be just
desserts but most interestingly what
happened there i thought
was what happened in those last five
seconds because that woman
appeared to hold the door open for the
criminal let's take a look
taking an air bed and leaving the store
on his scooter
no questions asked no one stopping him
oh are you stealing an air mattress from
walgreens
allow me
[Laughter]
that's what white people have to do in
an anti-racist society by the way if you
see a black guy stealing
a you know an air mattress or pretty
much anything you've got to
unless because you don't want to be
accused of racism you've got to hold the
door open oh please but
you certainly you're sure did you get
anything from the pharmacy because i
you know there's probably some
preparation ache back there oh lordy
lordy but
okay so in essence what's happening here
is that san francisco
which i would argue is probably the
worst of all the cities right now i mean
i guess portland you really could make
an argument
i named the big five on fox this morning
i was on harris faulkner show i mean i
would say the big five you got
you got portland you got seattle you got
san francisco
la new york like there's there's an
argument to be
made about which falls where on that um
but in essence what's happening right
now in san francisco
is that theft of less than 950 dollars
in goods
is treated as a non-violent misdemeanor
under california law and in most cases
for shoplifting the criminal is just
released so i want you to really think
about this if you walk into a store and
steal less than 950 in essence sure
maybe the guy at best buy or at target
or at walgreens is going to try to stop
you right like
the the guy who's sitting at the counter
you know usually and it's usually a
pretty fat guy that's just sitting there
right like trying to stop people from
walking through the automatically
opening doors
like he's probably not going to stop you
so in essence you can steal
949 worth of stuff and you're good to go
that means you could walk in to best buy
steal a playstation 5. how much is the
playstation 5 going for these days i'm
guessing around 300 bucks
300 bucks or so 400 bucks 400 bucks for
a play all right that you guys both knew
okay five
400 bucks for a playstation the games
are going for probably what like 50
bucks a pop
so you get 60 bucks a pot boy i really
now i know what you guys are doing now
so that means you could steal what like
six games roughly about six no maybe
even more than that you'd get like
you could get like eight games you could
steal eight playstation five games
roughly um work with me on the math here
uh you could steal about eight
playstation five games get a playstation
system you need an extra controller how
much is a controller gonna cost now
that's gotta cost a good
60 bucks for an extra controller those
bastards so all right so let's dump one
of the games
so you're gonna get about seven games an
extra controller and a playstation five
system
and nobody can stop you so why even pay
for it
do you see why san francisco is a
[ __ ] do you see why california
is crumbling do you see why they export
all of their bad ideas and then
send them to los angeles so right now we
have the former d.a this guy george
gascon
who was the horrific district attorney
of san francisco who ruined absolutely
ruined san francisco most of you have
probably heard the story
i was out to dinner one night in san
francisco
with candace owens and we had security
with us
and we were in a in an escalade it's a
fancy car and with security with us we
went to morton's steakhouse so it's a
nice day guys we're in a fancy
restaurant on a nice street
i left my bag in the car
they busted into the car stole my bag my
my computer was in there
my my notebook was in there you know
bunch of bunch of other stuff i just
bought the bag i was pretty pissed
um and when i tweeted out the shattered
glass all over the floor on the street
i tweeted out i said this just happened
to us in san francisco um i had
literally
hundreds of people saying well what kind
of schmuck leaves a bag in a car in san
francisco like this is a known
thing so all of this is just so
consistent
with progressive 101 they tell you
they're trying to do something nice we
don't want to arrest as many people so
we're not
going to do anything if you steal
playstations and if you break into cars
and if you
smoke crack on the corner or whatever it
might be they're trying to be nice and
what it does
is it increases the drug use it
increases the crime it increases
homelessness
and everything else but don't take my
word for it just go to any of these
uh cities just go to any of these cities
and see what's going on come visit us
here in los angeles here i'll do an
advertisement for los angeles come visit
us here in eric garcette's los angeles
where you can go under the 405 and under
any bridge on the 405 you can find a
spectacular
set of homeless people building shelters
that sometimes they sometimes put
extensions
one day you'll be driving by and they'll
go boy they've put up a really nice
little tent city there and then you go
the next day
you go man they really expanded that
thing these people are working
okay these people are working hard
anyway
i think you can see the point here that
that every progressive
policy does the reverse and now we
literally have 10
walgreens you know in a time of pandemic
a time of mass sickness
perhaps we need more drug stores but 10
bay area stores are closing
we've got people stealing air mattresses
white women holding doors for black men
as they run out of the stores
something is rotten in stink town
literally people
all right guys part one of my interview
with uh fox news's dana perino all about
her new book and some of the inner
workings
of the white house because she was
former press secretary for george
w bush oh and her new book was released
uh this morning that is up on youtube
and of course the full episode is up
totally ad free at
rubinreport.locals.com we will be
announcing another live meet up in the
socal area probably uh in oc orange
county
in the next couple weeks so you can jump
on rubyreport.locals.com and find out
what's what and uh all right that's all
i got for you today i have a busy day of
meetings and some other stuff i think
we're gonna have salads for lunch around
here
and you know what you know what i feel
good about today's show
and you guys were working hard you too
my director my producer working are you
know what guys
we're going to best buy and we're going
to steal some [ __ ] all right
all right who wants crash bandicoot you
want crash bandicoot is he still around
oh he is gone crash bandicoot's gone
sonic they got oh he's back
all right we're gonna go steal some
stuff at best buy maybe we'll maybe i'll
live stream it so stay tuned
and i'll see you guys later